this is a luxury this is an indulgence
this is the halo car for a brand right
now last year at Pebble Beach we
unveiled this the p1 some of those
customers came to us and said that they
have something even more extreme
potentially a race car or a track bar so
we've developed the p1 GTR it's a track
only vehicle only available to p1 owners
I'd say there's three things we've
really really ramped up so one is it's a
lot lighter we've taken out everything
that's non-essential we've also been
able to turn up the power the whole
chassis dynamics of the car have been
geared for the tracks of the cause lower
it's running on slick tires is running
on racing suspension for the car just
hopes the road I mean if the grip is is
phenomenal in a way I'm sort of saying
to them I'm maintaining your exclusivity
by not building incremental cars for
other customers but if you want a track
car you can have a track though my
personal estimate is we will have maybe
25 to 30 people who will who will take a
p1 GTR we took all the great attributes
that p1 and focus them on how we can
make the greatest tracker
what you get is a lot more than the car
you get fully immersed in our McLaren
driver training and then you get a
number of events then we're playing six
events around the world in really iconic
race circuits where we take the car you
turn up and drive it and you enjoy a
weekend of of driving hospitality with
McLaren so something very special and
unique that comes a sort of part of the
package in addition to the car
requirements of business you know we
need to run a successful business so we
can keep investing in new technology
investing in new cars building more cars
for the future so yes we want our
customers to love this car it is a it is
a halo for the brands I have something
as significant as this but also this
project will make money and we use that
money to develop the next car and it's a
sort of virtuous circle that if we if we
build great cars our customers will buy
them I'll just was buy the cars we can
spend the money developing more
you